y en directo a América llegó el momento
de hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge qué tal Muy bien cómo vamos Andrés
Bien bien también Jorge vamos a empezar
a hablar de Brasil con las críticas del
presidente brasileño Luis Ignacio urula
da Silva respecto al acuerdo entre el
mercosur y la Unión Europea bueno Lula
aprovechó Esta visita de úrsulay en la
presidenta de la comisión Europea y
criticó la previsión de sanciones en el
acuerdo mercosur en Unión Europea para
el brasileño la premisa entre los países
debe ser la confianza mutua de Unión
Europea exige garantías de que no
importará productos del mercosur que
contribuyan a la deforestación o al
cambio climático mientras Brasil y otros
miembros del mercosur piden renegociarlo
ya acordado sobre compras
gubernamentales el bloque europeo Espera
a las contrapropuestas de mercosur al
instrumento de estas garantías
ambientales planteada en el acuerdo
firmado en el 2019 pero que aún está
pendiente de ratificación la
confederación nacional de la industria
de Brasil y la confederación Nacional de
empresas europeas emitieron un
comunicado apoyando a este acuerdo
comercial que negocia el mercosur y el
bloque Brasil que es la mayor economía
de latinoamérica registró en 2022 un
comercio bilateral récord con la Unión
Europea de unos 96.000 millones de
dólares mientras las inversiones
europeas en Brasil rondaron los 277 mil
millones de euros escuchemos si parte de
este discurso esta crítica que hacía el
presidente brasileño
la premisa que debe existir entre socios
estratégicos es la de la confianza mutua
no la desconfianza y las sanciones
es paralela europea al mismo tiempo la
Unión Europea aprobó sus propias leyes
con efectos extraterritoriales que
modifican el equilibrio del acuerdo
estas iniciativas plantean posibles
restricciones a las exportaciones
agrícolas e industriales brasileñas
Jorge Hablamos ahora de la muerte de
Silvio berlusconi que poseía la tercera
riqueza más grande de Italia bueno según
la revista Ford su fortuna es estimada
en 6.900 millones de euros aquí un
repaso de su trayectoria en los negocios
donde También estuvo rodeado de la
polémica berlusconi Estudio derecho y
comenzó su fortuna los 23 años en los
años 70 cuando se adentró en el sector
inmobiliario y la construcción el
empresario compró participaciones en
periódicos italianos y creó el Canal 5
de televisión en los años 80 el primer
paso antes de mediaset su imperio
mediático luego compró el equipo de
fútbol hace Milán que lo vendió por 700
millones de euros recientemente su
conglomerado
factura anualmente más de cinco mil
millones de euros y cuenta con más de
20.000 empleados el grupo está dividido
en siete holdings cuatro de ellos En
manos de IL Cavalier con el 60% de este
imperio Y que ahora tendrá que ser
repartido entre sus cinco hijos entre
sus negocios está montadora la mayor
editorial de libros y revistas de Italia
y el tercer operador en Francia de
revistas de consumo que es dueño a
propósito de la red de librerías más
extensas de ese país los verduzcones son
Dueños del grupo medialanum controlado
por fin el grupo Doris líder del mercado
financiero italiano una de sus últimas
creaciones fue este partido Forza Italia
con el que se presentó a las elecciones
de 2018 y que le permitió Volver al
senado bien Jorge y ahora vamos a ir
hasta la ciudad de Nueva York donde se
aprobó el salario mínimo para los
repartidores de comida a domicilio bueno
según los datos de esa ciudad Hay unos
60.000 repartidores que ganan
actualmente una media de 7 dólares la
hora A partir del de Julio entrará en
vigor una subida salarial de
17,96 dólares la hora y el salario
mínimo aumentaría 19,96 dólares en abril
de 2025 según la ciudad mientras muchos
aplaudieron la nueva tasa de pago mínimo
de Nueva York los servicios de entrega
de alimentos incluidos Uber eat y
dordage argumentan que esta decisión
Podría tener Consecuencias negativas
para los trabajadores de las
aplicaciones la norma da a las Apps
cierta flexibilidad en la forma en que
van a pagar a los nuevos trabajadores
por ejemplo podrían elegir si quieren
pagar a los repartidores por viaje por
hora trabajada u otra política que se ha
creada a raíz de esta normativa Jorge
muchas gracias por la información
económica Entonces nos vemos mañana con
la actualización de las noticias de la
jornada así será
[Música]